it is much 26 to my name is Jess
McDonald you're tuned into gains but
knees and we do hope you enjoy the show
first up it's no longer just Santa who
cares have you been naughty or nice
Microsoft does to the publisher has said
that gamers who have what they're
calling a negative impact on the Xbox
Live community will soon be given
penalties like reduced matchmaking
pairings and could even have it which
access revoked Microsoft program manager
Michael Dunn has described the move
saying that players will fall into one
of three reputation categories on their
gamercard good needs work and avoid me
the players who have been abusive this
month will bring reputation warnings
although it's been suggested that there
could be good behavior rewards at some
point too is this totally crazy or could
it actually do some good in the internet
crap fight that is online gaming let me
know what you think another soft
microsoft said they're looking to be
pretty intense on game learning and
gifting xbox boss phil spencer has said
they're working to introduce new
marketplace functionality to the Xbox
one including the learning feature
Spencer said they're hoping to enable
both what gamers would expect and also
delight them beyond their expectations
now for all that Facebook buying oculus
VR madness that managed to hit the
internet just after we produced
yesterday's episode here's everything
you need to know the estimated two
billion dollar deal has resulted in
facebook now earning oculus VR Mark
Zuckerberg has said that oculus has the
chance to create the most social
platform ever and change the way we work
play and communicate he's assured that
Facebook understands the potential for
VR and oculus has said that in the next
10 years virtual reality will become
ubiquitous affordable and transformative
this is sort of bothered an awful lot of
skeptical game is spouting fears of VR
farmville including minecraft creator
notch who said we were in talks about me
me bringing a version of Minecraft to
oculus I just canceled that deal
Facebook creeps me out a tad more later
than notch though has predictably been
the original Kickstarter backers who
collectively put two and a half million
dollars into the original project the
oculus Kickstarter page has been
flooded with negative comments on the
acquisition including gamers noting that
they're disappointed this has come about
before the release of the consumer
version there's been an awful lot of
contention over what the backers are
owned by oculus particularly between my
producer and I this morning but no doubt
between everybody else to let me know if
you reckon the backers have been hard
done by and how you feel over the
Facebook acquisition of oculus either in
that comment section down below you can
do so on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald those are all the good things i
have to tell you today but i'll be back
with even more news tomorrow so i hope i
see them